WELL.
DAYS.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY SEAN SPICER HELP
BEING ON THE SHOW.
>> WE HAVEN'T HAD
COMPREHENSIVE TAX REFORM IN
31 YEARS.
WHEN YOU HAVE A 52 SEAT
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THEIR
ISSUE HIGHLIGHTED, THEIR
ISSUE ADDRESSED.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, MARCO
RUBIO IS GOING TO BE A VOTE
FOR US.
AND HE UNDERSTANDS HOW HE
LIKE A LOT OF OTHER SENATORS
MAKING SURE VOICE GET IT
DONE.
>> MIKE LEE PARTNERING.
>> CORKER,.
>> CORKER IS ONE THAT I
WOULD PROBABLY SAY IS GONE.
OUR LAWYER THIS IS WHAT I
LIKE ABOUT WHAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP DOES.
HE FORCES EVERYBODY TO PUT
THEIR CARDS ON THE TABLE.
YOU KNOW WITH EVERYBODY IS.
CUNSD ASSISTANT TRUMP.
DIDN'T WANT TO WORK WITH HIM
AND SUBVERT A LOT OF JEEND
RADIO.
DOWN TO THE END BIG TAKE
HOW IMPORTANT OTHER MAJORITY
IS WHAT THIS COMES DOWN TO
IS WE HAVE 018 IF CHUCK
DEBASE HOW MUCH TAX PEAKING
SURE THE PRESIDENT MAINTAINS
A MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE IS CURABLE TO KEEPING
THE PRESIDENT'S JOHN MCCAIN
IN THE HOPS SUFFERING FROM
TREATMENT AND WHAT IT DOES
TO YOUR BODY AND THAD
COCHRAN IS AILING.
HE IS THE SENATOR FROM
MISSISSIPPI.
REMEMBER THE REPUBLICANS
COCHRAN 76 YEARS OLD.
TIME TO GET A YOUNGER PERSON
IN THERE PLAY THAT GAME OF
MOORE WAS A MISTAKE.
MAYBE COCHRAN WAS A MISTAKE.
COULD HAVE A YOUNGER, MORE
VIBRANT SENATOR IN THERE AS
WELL.
PLAYS BOTH WAYS.
>> RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TO
CONCENTRATE ON GETTING 50
VOTES TAX BILL SO AMERICAN
PEOPLE CAN ENJOY THE FRUITS
A REPUBLICAN WIPE OUT.
>> I WANT TO STOP YOU RIGHT
THERE.
THIS STORY WAS A POLITICAL
STORY.
PRESIDENT CALLED PAUL RYAN
AND SAY HEY I NEED YOU TO BE
PARTNER OF MINE AND DRIVE
THE AGENDA FORWARD.
PAUL COMES FORWARD AND SAY I
WANT TO SAY.
I HAVE COMMITTED TO GETTING
THIS AGENDA DONE.
PAUL RYAN AT HEART IS A
POLICY GUY WHO FINALLY SEES
A REPUBLICAN SENATE AND
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT AND
HAS WORKED HARD ON SO LONG.
ONE OF THE TRAPS THAT WE AS
POLITICO OR "NEW YORK TIMES"
TRUE.
PAUL CALLED AND SAID HE IS
NO TRUTH TO THE RUMOR.
>> EVERYBODY IN PUBLIC
OFFICE OR ANYONE WHO HAS
BEEN AROUND THIS FOR A LONG
TIME THINKS ABOUT WHEN THEY
ARE GOING TO GET OUT.
>> Laura: I THOUGHT ABOUT IT
LIKE A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
EVERY NIGHT.
NO, I'M JUST TEASING.
>> IT'S A GRIND.
POLITICS IS A GRIND AND IS
HE A GUY WHO HAS DONE IT
SINCE HE WAS 25 YEARS OLD.
HE HAS A LOT TO BE PROUD OF.
HE SEES THE NEXT FEW YEARS
AS OPPORTUNITY TO GET
LIFELONG POLICY GOALS.
>> I THINK EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS AN AGENDA
REPUBLICAN BASE IS HIGHLY
SUPPORTIVE OF.
THEY WANT TO WORK WITH HIM.
JOB AS SOMEONE WHO AN
OUTSIDER AND DISRUPTER.
IS HE STARTING TO LEARN THAT
PRESIDENT AND COUNTRY.
>> I KNOW YOU KNOW OMAROSA.
I KNOW HER A LITTLE BIT FROM
WAS ON GOOD MORNING AMERICA
AND SHE HAD THIS TO SAY.
LET'S WATCH.
>> AS THE ONLY
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WOMAN IN
THIS WHITE HOUSE, AS A
SEEN THINGS THAT HAVE MADE
ME UNCOMFORTABLE THAT HAS
UPSET ME THAT HAS AFFECTED
ME DEEPLY AND EMOTIONALLY
THAT HAS AFFECTED MY
COMMUNITY AND MY PEOPLE.
AND WHEN I CAN TELL MY
STORY, IT IS A PROFOUND
STORY THAT I KNOW THE WORLD
WILL WANT TO HEAR.
>> Laura: SHE IS GOING TO BE
LEAVING THE WHITE HOUSE ON
JANUARY 20TH.
IT WAS A BIG FOCUS OF THE
WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING TODAY.
THEY NEVER TALK ABOUT
OMAROSA BUT TODAY LIKE WHY
IS SHE BEING PAID THROUGH
WHAT IS GOING ON THERE?
ANY I OBJECT SIGHT?
>> I DON'T.
>> Laura: WHY WAS SHE HIRED?
DOES SHE HAVE ANY
QUALIFICATIONS TO WORK IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> I MEAN, LOOK, SHE WAS
VERY LOYAL TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: SHE CAMPAIGNED FOR
HIM.
>> AND I THINK THE PRESIDENT
BROUGHT A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
WANTED TO FULFILL HIS
AGENDA.
AND THAT'S HIS PREROGATIVE
AS PRESIDENT-ELECT AT THE
TIME.
I WISH HER THE BEST.
BUT I DON'T -- I'M NOT
REALLY SURE.
>> Laura: SHE HAS A STORY TO
TELL.
DID YOU SEE ANY PART OF HER
STORY?
>> I DON'T.
>> Laura: GIVE ME SOMETHING
HERE.
>> LOOK,.
>> Laura: SHE IS A VERY
CHARISMATIC PERSON.
I KIND OF LIKE THAT.
SOME PEOPLE CAN'T TAKE THAT.
>> I WILL LET YOU LEAVE IT
AT THAT.
>> Laura: DO YOU MISS IT?
DO YOU MISS THE RUSH?
I MEAN, IT WAS EXHAUSTING.
BECAUSE I TALKED TO YOU
THROUGH THE A LOT OF THAT
TIME AND IT IS A 19, 20 HOUR
DAY.
>> SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
PRIVACY BACK.
>> A LITTLE.
I WAS PROUD TO HELP THE
PRESIDENT MOVE HIS AGENDA
FORWARD.
I LOWFD BEING ON THE
SUPPORTIVE FROM THIS THING.
IT'S A DEFINITELY A LOT LESS
STRESSFUL AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO DOING A LOT OF
THE OTHER OPPORTUNITIES.
I HAVE A BOOK COMING OUT.
>> Laura: I KNOW.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT YOUR BOOK.
>> GOOD.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK THIS
WE'RE WHEN WE LOOK BACK AT
YEAR FOR THIS PRESIDENT,
GIVEN WHERE THE ECONOMY IS,
GIVEN WHERE CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE IS.
>> YEAH.
>> Laura: DEREGULATORY
EFFORTS.
>> I DO.
ESPECIALLY IF WE CAN GET
THIS TAX REFORM DONE.
A LOT OF THE THINGS DONE IN
TERMS OF REGULATORY MEASURES
TO PEEL BACK TO GET BUSINESS
BOOMING AGAIN AND GET PEOPLE
HIRED.
ALL OF THOSE ECONOMIC
CONFIDENCE IS GOING THROUGH
THE ROOF.
I THINK WHEN PEOPLE LOOK
BACK OBJECTIVELY, TWO YEARS,
FIVE YEARS, 10 YEARS, THEY
WILL SAY THIS WAS A REAL
ECONOMIC POWER HOUSE OF A
YEAR.
PRESIDENT'S POLICIES AND
INITIATIVES THAT REALLY GOT
THE ECONOMY BOOMING AGAIN.